hi my name is shantanu prakash and i am
managing the restaurant educomp
solutions limited frontier and the
council that I'm part of is called the
emerging multinationals Council and one
of the really high impact projects that
we are thinking of doing is a project
that would show results in 100 days and
it is about going to both emerging
multinationals and established
multinationals and talking to them about
giving a jobs to 10 people and and into
these people for them to hire these
people outside the pool of people that
they would normally consider and
simultaneously talks to NGOs who would
provide these the raw talent to these
multinationals and also ties with
training providers who would dent repair
and provide the training and the
critical look for these people and
thereby going to impact not just a few
people but eventually creating new
models that is going to make a
difference in solving the large problem
of youth unemployment in some of the
emerging countries